hey guys Ryan Wright here and Elissa be
crazy we're gonna check out the video
today Batman Arkham Knight time to go I
have seen many and you've seen many
trailers - a Batman Arkham Knight not
sure how much more we're gonna have to
say but this is over seven minutes
getting a lot of requests for it so
let's see Batman going to war let's do
it
rated M for Mature he's black I can tell
that guy's black where's scarecrow
go get him talk or I'll crush every bone
in your body
okay okay working out of a pet house
inside of town I swear that's all I know
if you're lying I'll break the other one
the other one sound like Harrison Ford
now scarecrows got a safe house nearby
I'm going to pay him a visit
oh wow I'm an explorer in Gotham huh
yeah Wow
there you go buddy oh do we keep her in
there till we get the order to cancer
do your worst you know this is really
impressive considering it seems like a
go-to girl so yeah we have yeah all
tomorrow
look who it is
I can't say I'm surprised nice what did
he just shoot haha nice I think
freeze with faster reflexes
uh yeah there's a breakout boom
something tells me this this is cool
they made the fighting even more detail
yeah
hi-yah Pocky so fast I can't even tell
most of the times going on well that's
make things a little more interesting
Wow sir Batman is here were you
expecting to find me Batman I'm afraid I
must disappoint you take a look at the
chamber I want you to know the fear that
is coming do not back free we're walking
out of here nice and slow try anything
stupid a floral phrase down charming but
only one of us is getting out of this
cell Oh
nothing like a little natural immunity
why could you not regret later change
their clothes said he had a plan
oh please another out and Gotham would
be ours over my dead body I believe that
was the idea I told him that I wasn't
interested in his pathetic human games
and when I came to I was locked up in
that room
nature always win
will he ever learn you're coming with me
you only had to ask master Bruce that a
militia tackle over the city we need to
leave the master of understatement as
ever I need to know I'd like to be a
prisoner of that man I'm tracking
several transfer that's all funny there
are more on the way
activate the Batmobile weapon
Diagnostics
and on the street
this is commissioners gonna be hard
you want to be outside shop
those are drones Alyssa so sorry for
thinking otherwise those are not people
in there came across like it's million
in a last reaction cause that man
doesn't kill people yeah
but he does have weapons that could
easily
and so on say for the record there was
something that there was somebody
West
yeah
good to have you here Batman
bring her down to the
this is so cool yeah loving this I like
that it shows you how close you're
getting to your target I feel like I'm
playing the game yeah any progress with
the Leo Townsend analysis we're gonna
take a little while longer drop by this
one zero when you're ready and I'll show
you what I've got so far
who taught you to drive
they better [ __ ]
yes the open-world exploration of Gotham
City is gonna be one hell of an
adventure
it really will there's a way to feel
like this the tagline coming out this
month yeah what the tag lines are be the
Batman ps4 bundle shut up I'm talking
it's the tag lines be the Batman and
what better way didn't feel you could be
the Batman you could glide around you
could use the Batmobile you could fight
you can do the detective stuff you get
to do everything yeah as Batman and you
get explored Gotham what better look cop
burb way to explore top them then with
this game and you know just I mean first
off that didn't seem like seven minutes
at all not at all but in that there were
no loading screens there was nothing to
take you out of the game the whole time
you're in it you're immersed you're
right it seems like you are the Batman I
love that feeling yeah I felt like I was
playing this game and while I was
watching this then I was sad to realize
my hands were just touching my crotch
yeah mmm you know what though um I've
done what at least two other of the
Batman trailers with you right yeah
both of those before I didn't have a ps4
now I have a ps4 totally gonna get this
nice 100% I didn't realize was coming up
this luck yeah I'm really into the other
ones too origins City and um asylum
they're all [ __ ] fantastic yeah
silent was really good I only got to
play it for a very short period but I
liked it a lot she said period I'm gonna
get this game I'm gonna free order it it
honey Quinn Harley Quinn probably gets
her period - yeah I love it even a
cookie anyway guys if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you could check out Alyssa's
channel and she has a gaming channel
Alyssa be gaming
check it out yes yes those are the
titles of her channel and you can follow
us on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
where if we get enough followers we can
get pronto placement meaning less work
for me no benefit for you Facebook user
ha Facebook user so unique I love it hey
Ryan along with a few other Parent Trap
I love watching your videos I've just
ever posted a comment or anything since
I've never had a Facebook account till
last night
keep up the awesome work and make
Veronica happy when we I mean you are
inside of her KB walls of pleasure don't
have to shout me out if you don't want
to but I know you'll say yes anyway um
KB walls a pleasure what's that supposed
to be I think it's supposed to be like
her Cave of Wonders what does that mean
is she cheating on me is that supposed
to mean she has like other guys on the
side this is probably my favorite my
favorite request I don't understand what
it means love it what's the Cave of
Wonders you know what it means your
Bible Oh her badge I there you go you
are oh yeah it is a mystery don't know
what's like don't know what it's like so
sad there's a scene in wolf of Wall
Street where Margot Robbie is showing
her all her [ __ ] to DiCaprio yep and
DiCaprio is getting horny but she's like
no you can't have it yeah it's for Marc
I could totally see that yeah yeah I can
feel that anyway this bid is dedicated
to you Facebook user